so mrs president following weeks of
tense diplomatic talks between the west
and russia we see no sign of
de-escalation in the contrary we see
that both russia and now the united
states are amassing more troops on both
sides
so you see that diplomacy has failed and
now europe is spiraling towards a real
war
we should never give up
to work on diplomacy because
as russia has created this crisis
we do everything for diplomacy and
dialogue to be successful but we are
very clear also that in case that
there's any further military aggression
of russia against ukraine
that this will have severe consequences
and massive costs for russia we are very
much aligned with our friends and
partners like the united states the
united kingdom
canada and others and we have prepared a
robust and very comprehensive package of
sanctions
can you tell us more about this package
of sanctions what is the concrete
european plan
it is as i said a comprehensive package
in so far it's concerning the economic
and the financial sector
it would
limit the access of russia to the
financial markets of the european union
and it would limit russia's access to
crucial goods and technology
it needs and that cannot be easily
supplied and replaced
and therefore as we know that russia has
a very one-dimensional
economy mostly focused on
exporting fuel um
fossil fuel
fossil-based fuel
we know that
it is crucial for russia to have access
to these goods and capital and therefore
it must be in the interest of russia to
de-escalate but can europe really afford
to impose sanctions that could put its
energy supplies at risk can a disruption
to russian gas
really be entirely replaced because we
know that now it's currently covering
around 40 percent of europe's needs
entirely replaced just in case there is
a backfire
indeed
this would be a severe
situation but
we have done our homework and we are
working intensely intensively of
preventing and being prepared for such a
situation
when
there was the unlawfully and rightfully
annexation of crimea in 2014 for example
there was just one lng terminal in
europe by now
we have built more than 20
so we are able to receive lng gas from
other suppliers worldwide
i've created a partnership for energy
security with president biden
next week there will be a summit on this
energy security and of course we have
spoken to many different lng suppliers
worldwide who are very interested in
going into the gap that
russia would leave
and to supply lng to the european union
but more important
we've done our homework with the
renewables
the renewables we have massively
invested and they increased they had ice
level by now what the energy supply in
the european union is concerned with gas
and
the renewables are we are completely
independent
they are clean they are homegrown so
this is the future where we have to
invest in we are not i guess still there
uh finally i would like to ask you about
the eu as a blog
because we see uh individual member
states taking their own initiatives for
example the hungarian prime minister
visited moscow and president putin and
publicly described russian demands as
reasonable and sanctions as pointless on
the other hand we see france and
president macron setting his own agenda
et cetera so
what is the leverage that the user block
has in this stage in this global crisis
as it cannot speak with one single voice
there is
unity and a very strong alignment within
the european union we are in constant
contact i speak on a regular basis on a
daily basis with the
heads of state and government
we inform each other we align together
we give coherent responses or demands
whatever the situation is and what
hungary is concerned so far they always
supported the sanctions against russia
and
they have so far announced that of
course they will keep the unity with the
european union if it is necessary to act
okay brazilian thank you very much for
this interview thank you